thank you very much jason so it's my
pleasure to be here and
i would like to thank the organizer for
inviting me here so
what i'm going to talk about is the
anti-hardness of nuclear norm for
dancers and most of the results that i
present here are joint work with
leg handling who sits here
okay so
i don't have 100 slides like last
evening i have only 23 with references
so i better go slow right it's okay it's
just you know it's you were very
energetic
okay so so first we'll just talk a
little bit about norms and spectral
nuclear nerves for mattresses and
tensors so
mattresses are sort of
the starting point everybody knows
mattresses and i always say i paraphrase
max snoter to say that mattresses were
created by god and tensors by devil so
but so so that's but we'll do that too
so then we will talk it's not in this
order but weak membership and make
quality problems you need ball of norms
so this is very general and it's a very
nice
relatively simple results i think it's
new because maybe nobody was thinking
about this stuff but you know one never
knows so then we talk approximation of
norms so np hardness of tensor and
nuclear norms
then
banach theorem and symmetric tensors and
this generalization to p partition
metric density matrices so this this
part sort of a work in progress
so
i i mean somebody told me you have to
have too much too many equations on one
slide
23 slides
but it's it's they're all trivial but
i'll explain okay so so essentially we
are working with two fields complex and
reals
and so fm is i just usually
as a metrics person who use it is a
column space of a column space of
vectors
so nu is a norm if first of all for on
every non-zero vector is positive
and it's it's sub-additive and it's
homogeneous right
so we denote by being you this is going
to be the unit clause you need ball in
this norm and s nu which i hardly use
would be the sphere so it's all vectors
of norm one
now in this uh
talk it's very important to
talk about the dual norm
now
i'm using i can
use only complex numbers but then if
everything is real then y star is just y
transpose but if it's over complex so y
star is transposed and bar okay so
nu so the
dual norm is just the maximum of the
real part of y star x when y is over b
new so because
i can multiply by
by
phase as we say or for reals plus minus
one you can assume that it's already
absolute value
now
sometimes our norm is going to be
given by the maximum of the real y star
x on sum so okay maybe so so if i look
at the be new it's uh
everything is finite dimensions a
compact convex set so it has
extreme extreme points and so therefore
this maximum is just maximum on the
extreme points
so next so if i because we are finding a
dimension if i take dual of the dual
i'll get the norm
so for those of us who are not used to
thinking about norms what's the
kind of reason you use both norm and
dual norm
because we won't see because it would be
explained later but why not to
why not to answer your question so for
example a legend showed
together with healers that uh spec as a
spectrum norm is np heart now we are
interested in do in the
in the
nuclear norm which is a duel of that
that's the reason okay
so
uh
uh okay so so
on the other hand if i know that nu x is
a maximum of the this y star x when why
in some set s and a
and s is nonzero compact balance set so
essentially then
if i know this then essentially i could
say that the
the dual the ball of the dual norm in
the convex
convex of of s
now
i mean the basic things that one works
over real or complex numbers euclidean
norm so just x or x itself dual and
because of complexity sort of we always
will use this bxr so it would be
a
close ball of radius r
centered at x but the ball is going to
be just including ball so
just to remind you that we have
other norms which are close to euclidean
norse explainer so the the most
important norms are the euclidean norm
equals two the maximum norm equals
infinity and l1 norm which is p1 okay
so so now let's uh remind ourselves what
happens with me with the spectral and
nuclear node for matrices so fmn is
space of m by n matrices so on this
space we can also define just an inner
product it would be trace a star b and
then we have what we call the frobenius
norm so this is the
square root of sum of the absolute value
squares of all the entries
so
the
operator norm is denoted like that is
is going to be
the maximum of
the
a norm of ax when x less equals in one
now
if i look at all matrices of rank one uv
star
such that their
any of these norms are euclidean their
frobenius norm or this norm is one so
this is a compact balance set and so
therefore the you can also
i think most of the people know that if
i take maximum of the trace of av you
star which is the same as you star av in
that this will give you a norm
so
so if so in other words just
it already if you look what i did before
it tells me that if i take on the convex
hole of these
matrices it actually it will spend the
unit ball in the dual norm and the dual
norm to to this
the donor to spectronorm is a the
nuclear norm but anyway you will see it
also from the from here later so the svd
decomposition so it means that
you just take a
act from left and from right by unitary
matrices or orthogonal if you wish and
then
and then you bring it to a diagonal form
this matrix doesn't have to be square
but the other sort of more natural way
to say that singular val decomposition
is just a is a a combination or linear
combination of this u i v i star so they
are here this matrices e and the
sigma s are non-negative and this ui and
the
and so u1 up to un and v1 up to vm there
or vrx to the orthonormal
okay so the nuclear norm is just there
in this
if you don't just do anything without
any sort of thought you say what the sum
of singular values
so a the a is a
square of the fro of robinus i'm just
square it's sort of the l2 with respect
to sigma and the maximum norm is just
would be a okay
so so
the most important thing here
from linear algebra that if a is real
valued and i will take all this
all these norms over complex numbers it
won't get bigger it's the same one
because of this decomposition
now how about the complexity so the
complexity of the norm is omn
and the the complexity of a1 is just you
multiply by minimum because
so to find this is sort of you do
truncated whatever launches algorithm or
some other stuff so
so why actually
why mess with
l1 norm well the importance is sort of
when you you want to do let's say some
problems uh
let's say some problems one of them is
like the netflix problem so they would
like to guess
your taste with very few data so the
right was of the right way to do it is
to minimize
the nuclear norm and this is still a
convex programming and so
so in
in other instances also you mean
instead of
you do l1 norm so this is well
understood
and
that's why it's important in
applications okay
so so now just i want to remind you so
uh
so then i want oh
okay so what i want to do is just to
remind you that the
so if i take the nucleus
the nuclear
ball of the unit ball of the nuclear nor
in this space so this is it so you see
so essentially when you write a you
assume that the norm is positive or one
so you see that you see right away if i
write in this way or this are
non-negative numbers sum to one so this
is so
this is another way to say that the
certain extreme point of b nuclear is
exactly omega m f this this set of uivj
and now the and now there is this
you forget what what omega m n is okay
so let me just write it down
okay so we write it down so it's
okay omega
m
and f
is going to be the set of all matrices u
v
star
when u
in
f
m
and
now it's clear right
right okay so uh
so this is
so now uh
okay so
so so one important sort of trivial
observation you would never do it for
matrices is to observe that if you take
any decomposition
of your matrix as a sum of rank one
matrices and you take
then you will take the sum of each norm
of each factor and this is norm of this
one is norm of this one
then it's always upper bound for the
norm so therefore if you take the
minimum or infimum
it will be
the norm one because you have you have
the singular value the composition okay
so
so i gave a proof but now i'm starting
to see the time maybe too slow but it's
okay so so
so this so
so now let me show you
a sort of stupid method to try to
compute
the
nuclear nor for matrices because we have
this much better way because the
singular various but but when we go to
tensors we don't have that but this
method is variable so this method is
usually what we call alternating maximum
material alternatingly square what you
do you say okay so i fix y1 up to yn in
general position it means that all of
them are non-zero and any
maximal number fn is linearly
independent
and the
and then and n is big enough so using
let's say karate odor so n should be at
least m n or m times n plus one so i can
always represent
i fix these vectors now always represent
a as sum of x i
and now uh
out of all this representation that you
can view as a matrix you will find the
minimum of this norm so this is fixed
but this is varies and so this again
convex minimization so you can do it for
x now when you did it for x you fix now
x and do it for y and you switch it like
that and you every time you go you
improve you
improve this minimum and usually it will
converge usually to a stationary point
and
it would be local minimum if you are
lucky
most of the time
and so this is a way to try to find out
the
compute
nuclear norm without singular value
decomposition and they will try to do it
from for tensors okay so now we are done
i told you everything i know about
matrices that i need now we are going to
tensor so the tensor so just p i'm not
sure if i use this notation but m is
just m1 up to nd md and we take this
bracket of m it would be just all
integer from 1 to m now if we have j
from if we have d so because i'm having
mind
the
mod tensors of j subset of that
so uh
now we use a tensor we just tensor the
spaces and the as in matrices we can
denote it like that or don't bet that
now just we need some
piece of notation which i'm not sure if
i use that much but anyway we want we
want to contract one tensor with the
other one and this tensor doesn't have
to be the same d mode but it has to it
has to be k mode but this j1 up to jk
are sub indices of that so the
contraction just would be just you sum
on the all indices here so in other
words you kill all the indices which are
in x here so for example if you have
tau is the mod tensor and
and so you want to take this rank one
tether but you omit at k and you take
this you contract that this is going to
be a vector or in a fmk and so this is
the summation now you see the difference
between mattresses and tensors or this
is called hilbert schmidt norm
it's it's all history and this is an
inner product so
you can have some people of course abuse
notation from venus
with identical but
it's not exactly so so now let's just
essentially first let's go to three
tensor nuclear spectral nodes three
tensors so
what we have now we have here omega m
and lf so now it would be it would be
if you want as a sega product of or it
would be rank one tensor but each so
but the product of them equals one you
consume that each one is normalized to
be
of norm one but of course you still have
good choice with the faces and so the
specular normal just would be maximum of
the real part
of of this ratio or maximum of absolute
value of the real oreo part when this
varies on omega m and lf so this is
spectral norm
and they do and the
nuclear norm is just as in matrices
would be just the minimum of this
product
when you you take any
representation of a as a sum of rank 1
matrices and you sum the sort of the
norm of each factor that's the same and
you want it minimal
so again so
from what i explained before because of
this formula you see that each the
spectrum and the dual and the
nuclear number are dull each other and
the extreme points of the
of the spectral norm are exactly this
set of matrices
so can i ask essentially you switch the
definitions on omega
first it was a product of two balls and
now it's a product such that they live
in the the ending point lives in a huge
sphere so so because this is tensors and
this is matrices so was so what's not
clear so in the matrix case you said
norm of u equals norm of v equals
yeah it's the same it's the same you can
always normalize that it really doesn't
matter because if the product is one you
can fix it it's it's the same okay you
are right so it's it's the same
definition there but i should be more
consistent but it's the same okay thanks
so uh so so the starting point is a
tiller limb so the spectral norm is np
hard to compute
now what we want to show that the
nuclear norm is going to be hard to
compute and also we want to give
a reason why actually we are interested
nuclear norm so of the tensor so one way
you can say well you can also start try
to complete entries in tens or not in in
mattresses and probably like in matrices
it's the right norm to use this would be
the nuclear norm
now
so so here is sort of problems that i
think we already know the answer so if
you take a real tensor and you take it
view it as is a spectral null over r and
over c
is there you usually they shouldn't be
the same so in other words if you take
him in real tensor but go to complex
you will increase the norm but if a is
non-negative
then it's very easy to show and i will
convince you that here you have equality
that's easy
now let's go next
so uh
okay
so
so i think that i'm slightly a little
bit okay i'm
repeat some definition so this is my my
notation for the product of demo tensors
this is the ball
and this is the unit ball i discussed
that and so so now i just rewrite what
is the spectrum norm and what is the
what is the
nuclear norm
and i saw that there are duals and
so uh
so
i'm not sure so just to drop this see so
if i don't draw any field this would be
our complex numbers
so uh
so obviously
since the complex now as the
complex numbers are bigger if you take
this real you're going to increase
and
the norms
so
so here here so the claim is that so if
you replace a by a non-negative this if
you do just triangle inequality you will
obtain that they
that if you take here non-negative
tensor is absolute value it you will
increase the norm so this is again
trivial maybe i have even the proof or
something it just
it just follows from the fact
that
okay so
a
let's say a
sigma
say in f it doesn't matter okay sigma
so this is what's that it's maximum
on you have the triform sigma
okay without
so you have a
and you have uh okay so maybe it's
better to do business sigma x x
but then you don't see it so it will
suppose it's a i j k is three and this
is will be x i y j z k and you have this
one
this so this is this is
so this is
exactly
this part when i write it in full
but now if i take
inequality sigma
okay and now this the absolute value of
vectors x y and z they still satisfy the
still
satisfy the same conditions as before in
other words they are in omega and so
therefore you
okay and therefore you have
this inequality
okay where like this was
so
so this is works just in matrix like in
matrices now
however when you go to nuclear norm it's
not true anymore so this is in you have
inequality
this so
so in other words when you replace this
by a nuclear norm
this is not true and it's not driven for
matrices okay so
okay so that's so so now
so one way i guess so how would you find
the the how would you find naively the
spectral norm well you just over reals
or over complex you just do
again alternating method in other words
you fix all x's variable except of one
and then take maximum this is trivial
because of the kasheshwar's inequality
so you know which one vector to take the
next one and you alternate that
and
and you can do some stuff so this is
well known but in this paper that i have
with my students so
we have slightly
not rank one but
but what's called the r1 rk
approximation but anyway so
but how about the
trying to to do the same method for
spec for nuclear norm because this was
for so this this method was for
c for spectra norm so you can try to do
the same thing that i discussed before
but we nobody did yet
i mean
that i know of didn't yet any simulation
so again you just what you do you just
keep all variables access except one
fixed and then you put these
linear conditions and you find to try
minimize that
and then you change the variables
alternate okay
so so now we go to the
two
four tensors and and
bipartite density matrices so
you want to to go to do something to do
in uh
quantum mechanics so so we have so c m
by m is just m by m complex valued
matrices h and by m it's our hermitian
hmm is a
positive definite which means
positive semi-definite and this one
or positive semi-definite with stress
one so those matrices are called density
metric metrics and let's say quantum
system
finite quantum system represented by
density matrix
and the reason is very simple you want
eigenvalues of the matrices b the
probabilities to be in the state so so
they have to be non-negative and someone
okay now now we want to
to take so we have alice and bob
okay so we want to take bipartite system
so if two matrices we want to take a
chronicle product you want to take
chronicle product this would be
a matrix like that if this is entries
like that
now if we so that we have here now four
indices the indices of
ij and this came actually this are
arranged in lexicographical order of the
of things like that but we also can view
this creature as a foretensor
so we have sort of identification or
isomorphs in between these tensors and
products of these tensors so now
here is a piece of notation so we we
start with uh
let's say visit four by
four tensor which we have m m and n the
same so it's called bi-symmetric if we
see if the matrix this matrix c is
symmetric in this one so in other words
if we shift these two indices in front
then it is symmetric
so
if we call it by hermitian if we
shift these two
indices to front then we have to take
bar
and we call it positive definite if this
matrix is hermitian and positive
semi-definite so bipartite density
matrix
is would be just it would be
matrix leaving here but with m times n
and so so this is so this is a bipartite
density metric so we have two persons
alice and bob and
they are sort of interacting between
themselves okay so
something happens
okay so now so so now the most exciting
thing in
quantum mechanics which is now is the
entanglement so you want to do you want
to make more information it has to be
entangled so what is not entangled so
those are separable states so what is
separable states so in other words
roughly speaking alice does something
bob does something and that's it and
they don't
they don't do anything together so
mathematically
if alice just text produces one what's
called the
pure state it would be xx star and bob
like that so this is so in quantum
mechanics when you have two systems
interact it must be a tensor product so
this is what this so so then essentially
if you think carefully this if you take
convex combination of that this means
essentially that you have several
possibilities with several probabilities
so this is separable states so separable
states are sort of not interesting
because everybody works itself there is
no entanglement there isn't the spooky
uh let's say whatever einstein
uh
podolski and the rosina singer effect
okay
so so now
you want to characterize the
uh let's say the separable states and
you want to show maybe just that your
state is not separable okay
so
so let's select any tensor like that we
can define a trace and trace would be
very simple it just would be trace of
the
of the metric sort of like which
corresponds to that in other words you
start you take i equals jk equals that's
a trace now if you have a
rank one tensor then the trace would be
this one and so it's obvious you have
okay i forgot here absolute value this
you have always this inequality if it's
for real or complex one so therefore we
have this simple and nice theorem that
trace of a
is less equal than the nuclear norm
and the quality holds if and only if
a is
a scalar of bipartite or of separable
state so
let's see if i give a proof of that i
can okay so so let's let's maybe since
this is very simple and important then i
could give a proof here
so
yeah now i will have to start a little
bit to go faster but this is a more
simplex
so what you say okay so let's assume
that this is
my
decomposition of a over this minimal
decomposition with respect to the
nuclear norm so x i
y
let's say y
okay y y i
z i
and w i
so
the trace of that
so the trace of that
in absolute value would be less equal
than the sum of x i
times y i
times z i
times w i
now equality because this is the trace
traces actually you see because of this
fact here
when this
absolute value of x let's say absolute
value of x3 transposed x1 when is this
equals to
x
3 x 1
well
because of kosher schwarz inequality
they must be
essentially one
parallel to the other one and i have
star and so that's that's that's that's
the proof okay
so
so so here we have a
so we have a simple corollary that the
bipartite density metric is separable if
and only if its nuclear norm is one
because trace of a separable is one
and it's a nuclear node must be a
greater equal so any quality only if and
if it's by by so it's only if and if and
only if it's separable so this is very
nice so you see why nuclear norm is
important
however
life is not simple because good which
shows that even weak membership smn is
np hard so therefore weak membership is
the unit ball of the of this creature is
also npr because i cannot decide
polynomial well
i cannot decide easily or polynomially
that
that it is separable or not so now what
in our joint work with
leg hand we show that that weak
membership is also npr so this implies
automatically that the membership is an
np heart sure these np hardness results
are over which model because
since you are talking about complex
matrices the natural model might be the
bss model
that's in on that now now you are
killing me i assume that it's a so we
will see so this more so what i will
show in a few slides that essentially
this problem
is equivalent first of all that to the
click number click number you will agree
there is no need to model right if i
give you give you a graph and you decide
if you can decide the click number is
that np complete
click number yeah so that's so so
so that's it means for me that's you
mean that's so so for me i mean
uh
let's say for me the way i see it
because i'm not computer science go
ahead why don't you answer
yes okay did the reduction come out as
rational numbers yeah that would answer
his question right right okay so it's
the cook cup levin model it's a turing
machine the classical model because
ultimately our input is going to be a
rational number so it doesn't matter in
fact integers
so it's not real memphis they're
competing so for instance not in the bss
model no not not in the psf
okay we will see so let's see so so so
so this is just so this is as i said
maybe this answer your question that
click if
if i can compute a
spectral norm of special for tensors it
is exactly equivalent to
computing the click number of a graph
okay so let's see that so so let's start
so we have a graph on n vertices and a g
is is is an adjacency matrix and kappa g
a and a coupled edges adjacency matrix
copper is click number so there is a
very nice and simple result of what
instruction says that if you take this
maximum of just
quadratic form when x is a probability
vector so all possibility matrix exactly
one minus one over kappa g
okay so
so therefore it's np hard to approximate
this kappa g up to an order one over n
square because because kappa g is an
integer
so
so what we showed is that if we have so
this if you show that is the g induces a
special
for non-negative symmetric positive
definite tensor
and so whose spectral norm is this this
number so therefore the spectral norm is
np hard to approximate
within arbitrarily delta
okay so this is sort of we reprove the
result of healer and limb but in
slightly different setting so now we'll
show that that this is equivalent to np
hardness of the weak membership of the
unit well the spectral norm
yes
by the way the pcp theory will give you
the approximate complexity for greek
number much better
than a ratio like that you can you can
prove that's right but but i need i need
this maximum because i want to go to the
spectral norm
you know what i'm saying is
this the corollary of the 65s yes
so the corollary was a coco cream so
much stronger
yes i mean that's
that's okay for me it's that's good
enough well so it says that you are you
are much stronger colorado from that
right okay
so
so so this is sort of the the
let's say the heart of the argument so
so we want to show once we show that
this this
maximum is essentially a
spectral norm of certain tensor and
actually this stands or you can view it
also as a
just by multiplication as a bipartite
state so
so that's so that gives us that this is
np heart
now
so but this results sort of we can we
already know from
healer
and limb but now we want to show so so
so this we want to show this is
equivalent number one to big membership
if in the spectral norm
and once we know that then we is a
then we will okay and once we we know
that then we go we go and show that
that's a weak membership in the norm
polynomial if and only if it's
polynomial in the dual norm
and that is so that's what and this is
very general and that's and that's
essentially gives us everything we want
okay so now i need to increase my pace
five or ten minutes yeah i think you
have 10 minutes okay but anyway but i
have more slides okay only 11. okay so
let's see so okay so
so
every in the r and
all the norms are equivalent so you can
put there at this concept you've seen
this k nu and k new r so ernie every
norm is between capital k new x times
and small k nu x so so essentially and
you can assume those are rational
numbers and certain sort of the
complexity of this being you from this
point is the number of digits that we
need to encode these two can you and can
you
so for now i'm going to go a little bit
faster so it's easy to show the first of
all this is trivial that the spectral
norm less equal than the hilbert schmidt
norm that's trivial because it's just a
part of that
but also you have this inequality which
is sort of it's uh
it just comes very easy but i won't
dwell on that so you so so in other
words in in using for the spectral norm
then you then
the complexity of the ball is just
essentially the number of digits the
product of the dimension now for any
epsilon positive we and you have any
convex set or any any set so s bin
epsilon is a closed epsilon neighborhood
of
of being used so this movie is something
like that
here is my set and then you take balls
around it with epsilon so this set is
general set or being you but the balls
are always in r2
so this is this is
the sort of the thickening of the set
this is the thickening of the set of by
epsilon but there is also a sort of a
smaller set
which is
b minus epsilon so you take essentially
the smaller set would be what if left if
you take
you take this
cover of the boundary and what's inside
so this
everything black
okay so this one is s b
let's say new minus epsilon
this is a red one and everything bigger
one is the bigger one is
s
b new and epsilon okay
so
next so so this is so so what what
okay next okay so so now we go to this
standard thing that's called weak
membership and validity problem so
week membership is
okay maybe i did it here so
okay let's see
uh
so first of all
what is a membership problem you
determine if why isn't being you or not
being you what is a weak membership
problem so this is which big membership
prongs goes as follows either determines
that this is that your y is a slightly
bigger set b plus epsilon or
or it's outside the smaller set so
because it's approximation
and the weak validity problem is sort of
if you have
if you have this city is a hyperplane
which is given by
a rational numbers and gamma and epsilon
either everything
either every say in the small log in the
smaller set in the red set is separated
by gamma plus epsilon or
you know it's this or you have some
point in a bigger set which is greater
you call that so the basic results that
we use it's eugene and merovsky that if
there exists deterministic algorithm
solving the weak membership problem for
being you y and that and polynomial time
then there is a deterministic pro
algorithm solving weak validity problem
in this type okay
so essentially we are following the the
arguments of
governs so
so for for compact k r n and even c also
said m k c would be the maximum of all x
in k of c t x
so nu x is this maximum over the dual
norm
and if you take the dual norm then then
the dual norm okay so maybe it's
not clear but let's see so
this
so the the basic identity is nu x
it's k
u
x less equals and so this is the
standard green environment less and
greater equals one k u x
now if you take
new dual of x v we just change it will
be less equal one over k
u x
okay so this is all trivialities but
anyway so
so so now
if you do
correct
so if you take all these arguments and
so what is the problem the problem is
that being u
is a norm but small b here's when you do
delta you measure it with respect to the
standard equilibrium norm so you have to
compare so therefore you have this let's
say contaminants the sig ball is less
equal of b u delta s s equals that b nu
with the factor one plus k nu and
contained here and the same if you want
the new minus delta but you have to
assume this assumption there are these
contaminants and so you and from this
you deduce these
inequalities okay so they let's say the
technicalities right now so important so
now we reduce following glamour if can
you use greater equine 2 then big
validity in being uv implies weak
membership in the in the dual
and that's what we need okay and the
proof is just you just apply these
inequalities
so so now how i show essentially as
follows so weak membership in the dual
ball is big quality that's you didn't
name iroski and big validity in this one
is weak membership will be new this is
this is the stuff and so week membership
is equality so you see it's all
equivalent okay
so so now this says the next thing is i
want to to say what is newest polynomial
proxima so this is so i fix then the
euclidean norm 1 and i take an epsilon
which is
positive but let's say in this interval
and it's irrational and then i say that
this this definition if for any epsilon
like that and x like that there is a
polynomial time algorithm in
this in this in all these quantities for
approximation epsilon approximation of
new x
so
so now i claim the following so is so
these are equivalent news polynomial
very approximable
and weak membership is polynomial they
are the same
so
okay there that okay so the right okay
so you are right okay so this is a typo
it's i'm sorry this should be epsilon
okay so i change the
that's what happens and i change the
notation i want to keep so this should
be
well let's say this should be end plus
epsilon plus epsilon plus
k
mu
plus k nu okay typo
irrational and the number of bits
right to every single everything yes so
epsilon is rational that's that's
assumed here this one right
no x i don't assume it's rational but
then what does it mean
so the number of bits used to represent
okay so well it's a yes so you're right
so
x doesn't have to be rational
but x itself but i think maybe it's
enough but x doesn't have to be rational
but i want approximation but now we say
how would i know okay so probably i need
to assume that x is rational otherwise
how would i store it right and also the
number of bits in x should appear in
this
right
right right right you are right so okay
so have you have something i mean this
is uh okay
so we have to assume that this is right
agree
okay
so uh
so let's see so
so uh
okay so how do we prove that so so what
happens is as follows that that
so if new is polynomial approximate then
view membership is very easy i just
first of all i look at the norm of x
and if it's uh
if it is
less than one over k nu then the norm is
less than i know it's already here if
it's greater it's outside so the
question is i need to see what happens
if the norm max in this between two now
i take epsilon to be that and then i
approximate and then
if
x times omega y is less
than can you than this than it is uh
then it is in this set and otherwise in
this set so this is easy and the other
one also is other one is slightly more
trickier so
so if i assume that x norm is one then i
know that already by the inequalities in
its it's here so now i'm going to
what i'm going to i'm taking
i'm taking uh
let's say what i'm doing here
so i'm taking delta ah
let's see let's see what how to explain
it so now it assumes that this is so i
want to iteration assumes already i know
that this is in between two bounds and
now i'm
i'm asking i'm taking the middle of this
interval divided it by x
and and then i'm asking it's either in
this set or or
if it's in this set then i will conclude
that new x is okay so maybe
all right we're just about out okay okay
so
so so this is like the trick but it
tells me sort of i can now they
uncertainty the interval by three
quarter repeat this procedure so
so we are almost done so finding an
epsilon approximation to spectral norm
is np hard but this equivalent to weak
membership means the unique ball of
nuclear norm finding weak membership is
a uni spectrum in in the spectral norm
is np heart so so finding a nuclear norm
is then be hard and so with the
approximation weak membership of nuclear
noise equipment approximation of nuclear
norm and the approximation of eukaryotes
and pihar so
i think
okay so i think this is enough i
probably that's i'm not going to go to
banner theorem it's it's it's a
different topic
further questions yes
yeah um
the so the nuclear norm is the dual of
the spectrum norm
the spectral norm you define it at the
maximum over this omega right of the
multi-now function right right right
right and but what's about i mean the
spectral norm you can
take variations of it and not taking for
example the two euclid genome but some
kind of lpnoms yeah also a different
norm on y z w etc yes yes and could you
get same kind of results using this kind
of different
slightly different
spectral norm yes well okay so so there
are two things here so i mean so there
is a abstract result here if it's one
norm is difficult to compute that the
dual is different to compute right so
now the question is suppose i modify my
norms so how do i know that at least one
of those norms it's hard to compute
that's i don't know so that is a problem
so so this the
the basic idea was here that that i was
we were able to
to
to
to
take this particular muskin straws and
show that this is exactly equal to the
spectral norm
and that's that is the basis so so if
you say i have something different then
you have to come up
then you either to have you have to come
up with another sort of another
statement so you have to prove
a certain at once instance and one norm
that it is hot and be hard to compute
and then how do you do it so you you do
essentially it's also that in healer
limb but it's slightly different you do
essentially all the results that sort of
i know are based on this observation and
of course variation of this one so
therefore i don't know what to do if i
modify the norms
yes
in one of your slides you may if i
understand that you said that if the
nuclear nog is one then the tensor is
decomposable right it's separable right
no no so
if if i i have a bipartite matrix
and it's separate so let's let's go back
separable is equivalent to the
composable plus norm
in the composable they're all the the
composite meat but it's a sum it's it's
not the composable is not only rank one
is that it just it's a convex
combination of
all right okay so let's okay no it's
this is so you so
let's see
let's do it so this is a
okay here you see
smn is convex combination of this convex
combination it's not one that's a one
this is very easy to find right the
what's difficult what's difficult let's
see
so this to find if the vector is like
that that's easy but the convex
combination is hard
that's the whole thing if that's the
whole thing that that's that's maybe the
confusion here
the problem that is being considered is
you have the cancer
whose entries are rational numbers yes
it's hard to
compute in time polynomial in the sum of
the
end plus the right
right right
yes that's yeah so you are right here a
circle you see see how much and how
about complexity so you're right so in
other words the the result is as follows
so for mosken strassen the
for most construction result so what we
say so you so the for muscular stress
and the information on is only the graph
is 0 1 right everything now then if you
want to make it
to
if you so now if you want to make it
like a
density matrix you defined by the number
of edges so it's rational right and
that's so and then we say if i want to
compute that then it's exactly exactly i
will compute this one minus divided by
kappa nu and that's that's that's that's
that's the idea but now but now from
that i want to go to the dual norm and
for that i need as you said i need now
to to do all this that's what that's
what we need and that's what essentially
most of the work here right
well it's it's
so just a remark so this is this paper
let's
okay so just it's it's if somebody wants
to look on this our results so it's on
archive so this
this is the paper
so we post
okay so this is uh
we posted it there
i think yeah it was uh
10 right you posted it last month okay
thank you